[Musique]
il ya quelques années mon fils rentre de
l'école et on regarde avec ses grands
yeux comme ça et me dit papa je suis nul
je dois avouer que ça m'a fait un choc
ça m'a choqué d'entendre ça dans la
bouche d'un enfant de de 7 ans il avait
7 ans à l'époque le choc a été tellement
important que immédiatement évidemment
je me suis mis à vouloir chercher des
solutions pour voir comment ils
pourraient s'améliorer
comment on allait pouvoir l'aider à
rentrer dans le cadre finalement que
l'école lui demandait de d'intégrer
comment ils allaient pouvoir devenir
plus performant mais finalement en fait
cette cette façon qu'il avait eu de me
dire je suis nulle m'avait tellement
bougé que sa remise des choses en cause
chez moi et je me suis demandé quelle
était la nature de notre lien entre moi
et mon fils qu'elle était lequel était
le contrat en fait avec un père comme
moi j'imagine que l'idée c'était de
pouvoir se mettre devant moi je me mets
devant mon fils lui poussent derrière
à la façon dont il a envie de pousser et
je mettais plus ou moins tromper dans le
contrat parce que je me mettais avec le
poids de la conscience sociale à me
tourner vers lui a essayé de le rendre
plus de faire en sorte qu'ils
s'améliorent alors que la nature du
contrat n'était pas comme ça
la nature du contrat c'était je me mets
devant lui poussent derrière à sa façon
finalement si j'ai envie que mon enfant
puisse éventuellement un jour nous
proposer quelque chose de neuf une
nouvelle terre va bien falloir qu'il
pousse autrement et moi mon rôle c'était
de me tenir devant
ce que j'ai vu ça chez lui j'ai finit
finalement par aller voir la directrice
de son école et lui dire en fait je ne
veux pas que mon fils réussisse je ne
mets pas mon enfant à l'école pour qu'il
réussisse
je mets mon enfant à l'école pour qu'il
vive pour qu'il vive sa vie d'enfant
donc ils aillent à l'école c'est tout je
me suis demandée pour moi et je me suis
aperçu que finalement ma vi avait été
exactement ça aussi j'avais mon enfance
c'était des gesticulations pour attirer
l'attention de papa pour être beau à ses
yeux alors je faisais toujours en sorte
d'être plus je pensais qu'il fallait que
je sois plus malin plus intelligente et
plus rapide ou un plus fort ou que je
saute plus haut enfin j'avais toujours
tenter d'être plus et je me suis engagé
comme ça tranquillement sans même m'en
rendre compte sur la voie de devenir la
bonne personne le bon fils puis le bon
père l'homme bon et dans cette quête de
l'homme bon j'ai joué ouvert le jeu
ouvert des hymnes et idées à la
spiritualité j'ai voulu visiter des
mondes essayer de comprendre comment ça
fonctionnait lorsque j'ai croisé le
monde judéo-chrétien
chez moi ça surtout laissé la trace de
tuer un pêcheur de naissance tu dois
améliorer tu dois te purifier pour avoir
une fois de plus le droit de plaire au
père puis alors un peu plus loin encore
dans cette cette direction je me suis
retrouvée finalement entré en connexion
avec d'autres formes de spiritualité qui
elle aussi m'enseigner finalement que je
devais m'améliorer qu'il fallait que je
grandisse qu'il fallait que je me
purifie il fallait que je sois dans
l'instant présent pas dans le jugement
dans l'amour puis enfin au bout d'un
moment tout ça ça m'a fait un espèce de
l'espèce d' amalgame
une pression qui a fini en fait par
déclencher chez moi une forme
d'indignation
je ne voulais plus entendre et acheter
la croyance que finalement un humain
c'est un problème à résoudre que il ya
quelque chose qui tourne pas rond chez
moi dont il s'agirait de se méfier et
qu'il faudra toujours tenter de
s'améliorer
j'ai décidé finalement que j'allais me
comporter avec moi comme j'avais décidé
de me comporter avec mon fils c'est à
dire que je vais me mettre devant moi là
il ya franck et derrière il ya le petit
franck et je laisserais maintenant plus
personne me faire croire que
il est un problème à résoudre qu'il
s'agit de le rendre normale maintenant
en fait si on veut tordre frank may on
trouve ou franck devant je me pose
devant moi comme j'ai pu me poser devant
mon fils c'était bien pour moi ça de
ressentir ça cette capacité de poser de
l'autorité sur mon territoire et me
sentir voilà je suis franck et ça suffit
et après je me suis demandée en fait
comment ça pouvait fonctionner pour les
autres pour le monde et à travers les
milliers de personnes que j'ai vu dans
mes stages j'ai fini par obtenir des
réponses à propos de qu'est ce que c'est
que réussir la vie j'aurais demandé
c'est quoi pour vous réussir la vie et
je pourrais vous poser la question si je
vouvoyais c'est quoi réussir la vie
alors j'ai eu quelques réponses si on a
qui m'ont dit réussir la vie c'est
simplement être heureux
d'autres m'ont dit va réussir la vie
c'est remplir le contrat social réussite
sociale
d'autres m'ont parlé de vivre dans
l'instant présent que ce serait
peut-être ça la réussite et finalement
pour pour voir si c'était valable
je me suis je me suis dit que j'allais
proposer ces pseudos réussite ou ses
réussites possible à mon grand père sur
son lit de mort alors je les imaginais
ici j'ai dit voilà alors là il ya mon
pape il est là n'était pas très grand et
il est là sur son lit de mort et je vais
lui poser la question
j'approche et je dis papy en fait le but
de la vie c'est être heureux ah oui
d'accord t'as perdu deux enfants
ah ah et puis la guerre ah ok ah bah
écoute a pas réussi bah t'as raté ta vie
il faudra revenir ça marchait pas voyez
je vais le voir pour lui dire alors
papilles il fallait un réussir sa vie en
fait c'est la réussite sociale
voilà un tu es pauvre a raté une fois de
plus ben oui ma faudra revenir 1
vous voyez le jeu en voyez où je veux en
venir quand je lui pose la question de
l'instant présent l'instant présent
tapis un nom jeudi l'instant présent 1
ouais bah tu sais pas il s'en fout bon
ben vous voyez où je veux en venir
évidemment pour lui comme pour moi
maintenant
l'idée de réussir la vie est une vraie
question que je trouve presque absurde
aujourd'hui parce que en fait l'idée de
réussir la vie contient l'idée qu'on
peut échouer sa vie est ce que mon
grand-père a échoué sa vie est ce qu'on
peut dire ça parce que c'est vrai que
c'est assez simple pour nous de dire et
de parler de l'idée de réussir une vie
mais faudrait qu'on se mette ou à quel
endroit forrest placé pour pouvoir dire
d'une personne qui l a échoué qu'elle a
raté sa vie je crois en fait que la vie
ne nous demande pas de la réussir la
ville nous demande de vivre c'est tout
lorsque lorsque je vous dit ça
évidemment il ya toujours vos objectifs
vos envies dans la vie qui doivent
ressurgir et évidemment en fait les
humains ont des objectifs
on a des objectifs parce que la
jouissance de l'humain vient de l'idée
de transgresser des barrières dépasser
des frontières franchir des interdits et
que évidemment dans cette idée là de la
jouissance on a toujours ses objectifs à
l'intérieur de nous mais finalement
c'est pas des objectifs que nous pose la
vie mais que nous nous posons nous avec
notre imaginaire on 6e des points mais
finalement quand on a conscience que ces
points on les a fixés avec notre
imaginaire avec simplement la relation
entre nous et nous on comprend que ces
points nous servent simplement de point
de référence dont on va se servir
ensuite pour se situer
c'est à dire que si je suis proche du
point que je m'étais fixé je me sens une
bonne personne si je me sens loin du
moins bonne personne mais finalement ce
point là il ya que moi qui me suis
demandé de leur de l'atteindre
c'est comme si je fixais en un point
avec mon imagination et que avec ce
point je jouais même donné des des bons
des mauvais points mais je crois en fait
que en fait on va avoir des objectifs
mais ça n'est qu'un jeu entre nous et
nous entre soi et soi et je pense que ça
sert à rien de se glorifier
lorsque j'ai le sentiment de réussir ou
de me rouler par terre quand j'ai le
sentiment d' échouer parce que
finalement en fait c'est moi qui me
donne les bons et les mauvais points
quand
quand j'ai cherché à résoudre cette
équation
je me suis penché tout naturellement on
l'a vu plusieurs fois donc aujourd'hui
que la nature nous fournissez quand même
pas mal d'indicés et j'ai regardé le
fonctionnement d'un arbre et j'ai vu en
fait un truc tout simple qui va me
paraître un arbre ça tousse à l'endroit
où ça pousse et oui à l'endroit où ça
pousse pas il y en a beaucoup moins
c'est ça à l'arbre il pousse à l'endroit
où ça pousse pour lui alors pour un
accès très très simple nous on arrive
parfaitement à comprendre puisque
finalement il s'agit de coordonnées
géographiques extrêmement précise et à
cet endroit là la graine va trouver
l'énergie en dessous d'elle dans ces
nutriments et au dessus d'elle lui
permettant de pousser donc pour un abcès
très simple ce sont des coordonnées
géographiques et un endroit où ça pousse
pour lui je me suis dit si ça marche
pour un arbre
moi qui ne suis pas moins qu'un homme il
ya sûrement un endroit où ça pousse pour
moi et je crois aujourd'hui
qu'effectivement il y à un endroit où ça
pousse pour nous alors bien sûr cet
endroit ce n'est pas des coordonnées
géographiques
dieu merci vous imaginez si on disait ah
bah non toi c'est là désolé ah ben
au revoir maman ben oui un désolé c'est
pas la même maison ce serait un peu
compliqué évidemment en fait pour un
être humain
ce ne sont pas des coordonnées
géographiques parce que les humains ont
des racines mobile et puis un être
humain ce n'est pas un avoir humain ce
n'est pas un féru main c'est un être
humain est finalement l'endroit où ça
pousse pour nous c'est un état d'être un
état d'être particulier lorsque vous
avez complètement oublié que les
objectifs que vous étiez fixé était un
jeu entre vous et vous vous mettez dans
une circonstance où vous vivez un
endroit où il y as pour vous l'état
présent et un peu plus loin là bas
l'état désirez plus il ya des quarts
entre l'état présent elle est à désirer
plus vous souffrez plus vous êtes
frustré lorsque je veux à la manière
d'un arbre me retrouver à l'endroit où
ça pousse pour moi c'est très simple je
dois rejoindre ce que j'appellerais un
état d'être particulier et c'était à
d'être c'est la conjugaison
de l'état présent et de l'état désirer
c'est à dire que le monde est à présent
c'est que je suis ce que je désirais le
plus être au monde ce que je suis
maintenant ma grande est ma petite
version le gars sympa et moins sympa mon
arrogance et ma gentillesse mon courage
et ma lâcheté la totalité de ce que je
suis c'est mon désir c'est ça que j'ai
envie d'être simplement un humain pas un
bon humain par un mauvais humain un
humain et quand je me mets à cet endroit
là landrush conjugue est à présent il
est à désirer je suis à l'endroit où ça
bouge pour moi à cet endroit là ça n'est
plus franc court après ses objectifs ce
sont mes objectifs qui cherche à me
rejoindre
c'est vraiment la sensation que j'ai
depuis que je suis ici à cet endroit là
à l'endroit où ça pousse pour moi
finalement aujourd'hui j'ai entendu
beaucoup de témoignages
peut-être un peu moins que vous parce
que j'étais un peu dans les coulisses
mais dans les témoignages que j'ai
entendu j'ai entendu beaucoup de
personnes finalement nous montrer que
les moments les plus difficiles les plus
les plus douloureux les plus
dévastateurs qu'ils avaient vécu avait
été également les moments les plus
fondateur et moi ce que je vois dedans
ce sont des gens qui sont retrouvés face
à un événement dans la vie qui leur a
demandé de se remettre
naturellement à l'endroit où ça pousse
pour eux parce que la vie venait leur
demander d' abdiquer de leur désir
incongrue et puéril de vouloir la
réussir et à cet endroit où ils se sont
trouvés à l'endroit où ça poussait pour
eux ils ont pu défier l'impossible en
tout cas en tout cas pour mon fils dont
je vous parlais tout au début
aujourd'hui il est pas le premier de sa
classe il n'est pas le dernier de sa
classe mais il est à l'endroit où ça
pousse pour lui merci
merci merci